it's funny because everyone approached
the quarantine differently did you get a
lot
accomplished during the quarantine are
you one of those people that took care
of stuff
i did the mistake and i'm sure a lot of
people did too those first couple weeks
i mapped out
i'm gonna get all these books read i'm
gonna have an exercise
regimen i'm gonna use this time wisely
and then
a month later i was having cheetos for
breakfast and
like re-watching uh like like shows i'd
seen a million times didn't read any
books i i
it took me a month to just and i
just went crazier than a barn full of
clown pubes like i was just
out of my freak look wait a minute i'm
not what are you
you got to explain that one i'm not i
look i don't want to get cancelled for
that
okay i'm just saying clown clown pubes
are perfectly natural clown sex is fine
whatever
you want to do i'm not judging i'm
saying
cr the crazy is the person who gathered
up enough
pubes to fill a barn that is what i i
just want to know
that i'm not putting the crazy on the
clown pubes
it's the act of gathering yes enough
clown pubes to fill a barnum please
yeah i'm just clown pube shaming hurts
all of us
and i don't want that to be i
just don't want that to be a problem uh
what about this what about the fact
because you're a guy
very thoughtful and i look to you for
the answers
why i just said barn full of clown views
i know clearly a mistake on my mind i
got drunk with a doll in 2013.
listen to me but in this post-pandemic
world
do you think life is going to be
different there are schools of thought
some people said it can be radically
different some people say we're gonna
drift back to what we used to be
absolutely nothing is gonna change i
remember
right when the pandemic started and it
got really bad i would sit around with
my wife and say well you know the
buffets are never coming back and kissed
that goodbye
buffets are going to come back so hard
and they're going to come back in that
defiant kind of like are you a [ __ ] or
can you come and eat at the golden
corral
we don't have any meat like they i i
swear it's gonna be
like we don't have any of those woke
sneeze guards like those
liberal left coast weirdos like come on
out here and
get on out to our coffee
welcome zone it's just gonna be
we're utensil-free yeah
there's no sink in our bathroom
we'll build a caesar salad right in your
mouth
[Laughter]
can you take no sneeze guard dining or
can you not make love to your wife
buffets are going to come back here all
the cruise ships are already sold out
yes they've sold
their people have spent a year watching
cruise ships
mired off of coast because they were
full of plague and death
and now they're like well i guess
they're they're discounting it now
i mean if the plague ship is expensive
then no but if they're gonna
throw in you know a free water slide
passes like how can i say no
nothing will nothing will change nothing
will change all right and it's sad